is this your new fight meaning before
kovid you didn't talk about vaccines i
doubt that this was something that was
on your radar or was it but is this your
line in the sand like this is what i
stand for now yeah i mean i think my
fight has always been freedom you know i
came into this business battling the gop
establishment really i was battling
republicans my issue was debt my issue
was like why don't they care about the
debt you know specifically republicans
or just politicians well i was mad
because republicans claim to care about
fiscal conservatives right a lot of
republicans were claiming to care about
those things and weren't doing anything
about it and i saw the rise of the tea
party movement and i know they've been
vilified but i went to a lot of those
rallies and a lot of it consisted of
regular people who were tired of all of
this nonsense
so i think you know freedom has always
been an issue that a hill that i'm
willing to die and i have never seen
anything like this unfold in the united
states of america i saw what happened i
mean i come from new york city
you can't go into a restaurant without
showing a vax car this is the united
states so i have a two-year-old and i
look at him and i'm like you're not
doing this to my kid like i will get out
of here i will take my money not that
it's a lot but i will take my money i
will take what i do for a living i will
get out of here and let these cities
that are doing this to people let them
sink let them figure out that you can't
act this way so this is my hill to die
on not because it's you know i i'm not
someone who's like i'm an anti-vaxxer
you know that's not my position my
position is how are we now in a place in
this country where someone can't make
that decision for themselves and these
pharmaceutical companies that have
liability protection why can't you ask
about that why can't you ask questions
and just say hey why is that the case or
what are the side effects or
gee you know my risk assessment for me
is not the same as the risk assessment
for a 90 year old with four
comorbidities these are not questions
these are questions you're getting
censored for okay are your parents facts
let me they are so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]